let's say it's a detective story so
something totally different what are
some of the character composites they
would have on the storyline well the
detective is a major character type each
of the genres by the way has its own
unique hero already created and one of
your jobs is the writer when you're
working in a particular genre is to know
what is the character type who's going
to be driving this story another
detective is one of the great character
types and maybe the great character type
of the 20th century um the detective
story is essentially a twentieth-century
genre and it's built on the idea of
solving puzzles it is the most mental of
all the genres so of course our classic
detective is the most intelligent of all
genre heroes and the the detective of
that to this day virtually every
detective show is built on is Sherlock
Holmes for example the tagline the
premise line for the Mentalist so
literally the way it was sold is that
the show creator said to the executive
what if Sherlock Holmes and Angelina
Jolie had a baby that's what sold right
and then you have right in that premise
line the appeal of that show that's what
any good premise will give you in one
line the fundamental appeal of the show
which is the smarts of Sherlock Holmes
the beauty of Angelina Jolie right we
put those together and we have a very
attractive character who will drive an
entire show over multiple seasons so
again each this is why I've always put
so much emphasis in my story classes on
knowing the beats of your genre which in
food knowing the main character who will
drive that genre
you